that feels good
that does not feel good jetpack escape
you mean jetpack joyride
i'm not a wiener i'm not oh okay i get
it i understand it okay
jetpack cool why is it cool oh because
i'm not gonna die
is it justin bieber cool is it getting
better cool [ __ ] is it cut up i like
school oh that's pretty cool
thank you for the opportunity to not die
thank you for giving me a chance
oh my god i made it
on my first try um
adventure pic oh my god oh my god look
at this piggy
that is the most adorable thing about
okay i might die that is still the most
adorable thing i've ever seen in my life
look at his little legs
oh my god look at his little legs
they're doodling so oh you can't give me
i'm already ducking
bye mr enderman oh my god
that is the cutest thing i've ever seen
escape
plus ball fall ow oh ow okay this was a
good start
i love the shards of glass in my neck
that's definitely gonna help
okay hooray ball fall
ow my legs but that's all right can i
just can i just can i just okay wrap
my leg around my head ugh okay didn't
need that anymore it was just weighing
me down at that point
yeah come on come on come on
come on come on don't yeah yeah come on
come on squeeze your butt in the cap
that's what she said
that was that's what he said to she hey
come on go somewhere oh what is this
crap
i don't even want to do this anymore
come
fight in the arena this is the one i had
in mind when he said there was gonna be
a fight
i'm on a bicycle why would i be fighting
anybody
excuse me old man were you my
competition something has happened to my
leg but i'm gonna ignore
excuse me are you the fight that i'm
supposed to be having ha ha
very funny where's the real fight even
on my bicycle i'm way too pro for you
oh a car good job you missed what is
this
what is this baloney what is this okay
all right who throws glass really
who throws glass maybe you kind of
deserve that
excuse me just running over your corpse
don't mind me hi
whoa why am i still on my bike
oh god somebody i'm still on my oh god
this is a nightmare
if they don't stop me i think the bike
seat has officially gone
inside my own anus get rid of it
oh it exploded right into my crotch free
fail why am i failing instead of falling
ow okay
okay point boink
boink boink boink doing good so far
i wonder if anyone realized okay sun
exploded
arm's gone never gonna be able to oh
where am i going now am i dead yet miss
me
douchebag still live escape school hey
you can't leave here get back i'm gonna
get you out of here timmy
bye everybody can't read what you're
saying it's going by too quickly bye
hello lady would you like to come home
with me how about you no no thank you
bye bye goodbye lady i don't think i'll
be able to reach
bye little kid have fun goodbye
everybody
sorry old lady goodbye goodbye kids bye
thank you
i think you have officially stabbed my
crotch
okay didn't make it that time either
principle speaking we seem to have a
vandal that is capturing a student
escaping
please use the emergency weapons what
does that mean what do you mean by that
okay thank you good try kids well done
neon jet wall what even makes this neon
there's one red line is that officially
neon
these days okay that's a bit more of a
hoof
tip deeper
wow that was easy i did it i rarely ever
find success
trampo sword throw oh well isn't that
just delightful look at him they look
like they're having fun
time to murder hope you enjoy your
trampolines in hell
impossible 87.93 per oh
okay just gotta ignore the big sword
okay there's my head up there that's
convenient
thank you ah thank you yeah miss me
oh yeah miss me oh my crotch
this seems painful oh i was going to
make it
can you play the wire oh
this is hard why is this one so hard
that's not what she said okay
yes get out the box no box can keep me
with my rock hard helmet head
now if i could just flip over like a
bose thank you
goodbye it kind of hurt
epic sword throw what the hell are you
doing down there
what is wrong with this entire
environment oh
yay freeze fall don't know what that
means okay there goes my
all righty then car crap
that's awesome i want to do it let me do
it let me do it come on let me do it i'm
gonna pop a wheelie come on mr crow okay
i don't recall oh i do not recall
the spongebob tv show
being this horrifying thanks mr krabs
hi patrick penalty kid with a big
penalty kick
after the beep tap rider up when you
want to shoot
ah death course
why is it called the death course i
wonder i wonder why it's dangerous
oh these mysterious disappearing blocks
seem to be impeding my progress a little
bit nope
not today not today everybody sorry kid
did you get hurt over there
i didn't even notice a thing bye
everybody i'm gonna go there
oh i'm dead okay goodbye world
multi-epic level okie dokie
simple glass break okay that one didn't
want to break but i'm just going to
persuade it a little bit
change your mind hello please sir
oh okay kid you might not want to look
at this
something weird is happening here and
i'm doing a rhythmic dance and you just
need to calm down a little bit
uh and there's my butt and you're
welcome kid you're welcome
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome everybody you're welcome kid
you're welcome
okay test your okay well i
i don't know what well i
why okay test my arms don't know what
that means
oh my heart life or death
well i didn't even okay didn't even
all righty then just gonna move on this
old man touches kids
how dare he yeah well okay that was
awfully simple goodbye
i'll pass my judgment on everybody else
this man murdered my parents i'm bad man
you son of a [ __ ]
i don't know if that actually did
anything but oh god
that was one hell of a rope this is your
wife she cheated on you
that doesn't mean death i can't even
press no no something is new
something is compelling me depressing oh
god no
honey my wave oh god
horrible oh god this [ __ ] die
die a million times die die die die
goodbye yay goalkeeper
got it oh i put it in the goal
that was anything right right okey dokey
well this is fun
so what do i do with this
i'm just waiting for the excitement to
kick in whenever that may be
anytime someone wants to tell me that
i'm having fun
cool yeah look at this it's a lovely day
in the park how well made this level
okay that is a big ass fish why am i so
tiny did i just die
oh crap
yeah back
spike fault ew let's do it let's do it
first try this is really the first try
guys and i'm gonna make it
yes i am so good obstacle course black
black like my soul harpin's missed me
harpin's me okay that one got me right
up the nose but i'm not even gonna worry
about that
dancing knives more like dancing borings
bye son
rotating glass missed me miss maine
rope swing orange let's see if i can
actually be good at something
okay oh god oh am i supposed to go to
here
was i supposed to do it to this oh god
thank you that was only on
ball through deluxe
are you kidding me wow
okay that was my first try car wash test
working at the car wash i think i broke
the car wash
oh yeah oh yeah ooey
my brain very hard spike fall
well let's see what you got really
really
really really really oh am i gonna make
it
i did
shotgun vengeance oh no what
they just seem to be having a fun time
over there i don't know why i need
vengeance
oh is that my wife or something sorry
just seeing what this does glass level
two
i suggest not to jump okay i jumped i'm
so sorry
i didn't mean to oh please forgive uh
okay trying again not jumping this
okay it didn't i didn't mean me too it
just ramped i'm i'm so sorry
okay cool thank you
oh tsunami's to die kid
kid please save yourself save yourself
oh my corpse of dead son i'm gonna just
go on my that is a long-ass name
okay bye oh you think you're katniss
everdong
oh god survive go upwards how do i do
that oh
i get what you're gonna do hey all right
you kiddies you break that glass
you could end up glassing shove it up
your ass until it breaks i don't want
any excuses over here okay
oh oh you give it up already santa's got
to do everything himself
said always have to do everything
himself just like drink all that eggnog
and drink all that jack daniels
it's like all that booze and all that
whiskey and all that other eggnog
impossible okay that's up my butt
impossible well geez isn't that a little
bit rude a bottle run another one eh
oh these are so drool where did my so
there's my son's head i was wandering
from okay
oh god thank you
jet pass fall thing i don't know exactly
what the name of this was
and my leg is back to nora okay death is
an alternative i will accept
this one is called dead square so i'm
just assuming that it's
gonna operate as the name implies here
we kill them all squish squid squish
well this might actually be better than
the deathball i might just be able to
kill them all
yes after i'm done breaking this glass
of course i will kill them all
eventually i'll get more to kill because
if they killed them all
okay prepare to do a double under roll
that was a close one for santa claus
whoa now i get to breakdance
epic nia oh my son are you gonna be okay
up there
you gonna be good well i'm just gonna
carry on without you so
you have fun over there in the weird
playground you're playing with
i'll just be on my new i'm going to ah
mega obstacle course nope not today
there
get out of the way oh god what am i
doing
why why why on my butt oh let me go
please take my son but let me go
ah ah
okay all right harpoon run
epic why is it so epic all you've done
is what everyone else has done which is
take my son away from me
and then you've tried to shove them up
my crotch but that doesn't work either
i'm just doing way too good this
playthrough
now santa gets a chance to kill them all
don't prepare all you bastards
you're really gonna get it even my clone
of fanta will probably
reel me you're all gonna die all of you
are gonna die
woof
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching
if you want to see more happy wheels
right now check the description or click
the annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist
and if you want to see more happy wheels
in the future please click the like
button to let me know
thanks again everyone and as always i
will see you
in the next video bye-bye